I got this from my dad he said I only
play games if I know I'm gonna win
people might take a lot of different
things from it but I'll tell you what he
meant by that he wanted to do all the
preparation and have all the unfair
advantages he possibly could before
taking the first step into a game and I
would say that that's probably the
biggest difference between people who
are big time winners and everyone else
is that once you learn the rules of the
game then you learn how to stack the
deck and you can do it ethically and you
can do it legally easy way to stack the
deck wait longer than your competition
you can come in with unfair advantages
simply by measuring success on different
time Horizons or measuring a different
metric for success I think that that
lens can be used by most people and most
people don't do that because they don't
even know the rules of the game that
they're trying to play